previously on the walking dead I don't
know who you are what you did I said my
to become a better liar
oh [ __ ] I am
well this is as far as we're going
ah how's it goin bruh
my name is Prabha
welcome to walking dead I'm gonna do
this episode a little differently um I'm
not gonna talk while there is dialogue
so if you think it's boring if I do that
I'm damaged this place didn't get looted
all right um let me know but otherwise I
will shut up what is this when I hell
did I just pick up a razor blade
Clementine are you okay
seriously are you good hi um can I get
you anything get you anything I'm okay
maybe I'm a little hungry all right I'll
see you about that um we should get into
it a name are you okay
what oh yeah yeah apart you know like
what I'm good that's good yeah I think
so being good is good despite the
circumstances yep
any conversation between these two so
awkward being good is good your nose for
groom nothing is he okay yeah I think so
you're doing a good job we'll sit tight
all right girl oh girl
let's give us food the lady wants food
I'll make sure you get her food energy
bar I'll give that to you here go there
no I click Ron say everything okay
mm-hmm okay uh absalom much but here you
go thank you your wax course has a Care
Clementine he's my darling oh my darling
Oh My Darling Clementine is a TM god
damn it why couldn't we steal that all
right let's check on with the others
let's give her something it's not much
but here you sure yeah you're under
quite a bit of stress Thanks that's a
really sweet don't mention it
don't mention it maybe we should talk to
her
how's it doing I'm not sure I got your
name it's Lee Wow no she my dad Larry
I was just doing what I had to earlier
everyone was he didn't have to call me a
[ __ ] in front of my people I don't need
that [ __ ] all right it's hard enough to
be in charge of people's lives without
some dick cutting him down and that
violence before with my dad but didn't
hope well your dad started it
seriously seriously he was gone you're
from here I work at Warner Robins the
air force base yeah
know what pilot nah just mechanical
admin stuff I deal with a bunch of
[ __ ] and bureaucrats all day
sometimes a plane I'm lucky you I woke
up at UTA I don't even know who that is
University of Georgia I think there's
something so what's wrong with your dad
works wrong with he's got a heart
condition
he takes nitroglycerin tablets pretty
regularly I've seen a few bad attacks
that he couldn't get over and needed to
go to the hospital yeah that's not
really an option right now I'm just
trying to keep him relaxed
well he's got a temper all right now
[ __ ] you yeah he doesn't mean it
it's just that yeah
we got kids have kids here family he and
I are a family I'm just saying some
people can't handle a temper like that
hey belly seems like you kids it's just
his way
don't make him the reason everything
screwed I was a good point huh
where's her mom don't worry about it
she's with me oh you guys aren't
together oh no I'm not her dad I found
in a house when getting out of Atlanta
she'd been surviving by herself I think
the girl's parents didn't make it Oh a
herd of answering message they were in
Savannah she was home with the sitter it
wasn't good
well she's lucky to have you yep she
sure as hell is I'm not gonna have her
what about what do you think about all
that uh I don't really feel like I get
back to him now continuing this
conversation that much it's kind of slow
and doesn't really go anywhere
what it what are we doing are we heading
out
Oh what is des couldn't the time stay
back
Jaffa Jaffa but it's but it what I what
in hell I can't I can't think about them
in here who
what it
there's a photo over there ah let me
shake it out
ah it's him but no
nah
find anything
hide it
uh forever
what's going on here might help us track
down the keys to the office I know who
you are
nearly Everett you're a professor at
Adams who killed the state senator who
is sleeping with your wife it was your
parents store folks around town no the
owner's son got himself a life sentence
but I'm a reporter for wabe in Atlanta I
paid attention to that trial maybe
you're a murderer
but I don't really care frankly that's a
skill that might come in handy
oh wow did you tell anyone out there who
you were or that you were tied to this
place
no but sticking the first names for a
reason
all right you seem like an okay guy and
the last thing we need is drama out
there you've got this little girl to
take care of it look don't make me wrong
on this I don't plant good because of
this last longer than a few days and
you're a detriment to the group then
we'd have a problem
a few I'll just keep it to myself
thank you girl burns
don't worry about it all right he's
gonna get some mm-hmm in the pooper
what anyway I think it's a little weird
how she just lets him walk away with him
with the girl like he's still a murderer
here's a nice guy and all maybe didn't
murder him we'll see what's interesting
it's real how they just tell you like
what looks like we're here oh maybe
protector at least it's really sad
so they own the store huh what about
this place a store leads to the back
Ellery
all right let's talk to Clementine
everyone out there seem all right to you
yeah well maybe not the sick guy yeah
we'll keep an eye on her good boys that
thing in the bathroom you tried to get
me yeah I'm scary huh but you stopped it
yeah I did can you do that more I'm not
gonna go looking for I mean get the
dangerous ones I've got four that's
funny
so I'm gonna keep looking around okay
let's keep looking around
do we need to look for kick back into
the drugstore with me okay Lee stop your
oh you're not bad right
I wasn't asking me that that lady said
you killed someone was that because he
was one of the things trying to eat you
um what do you say to this
it's complicated sometimes things happen
or you do things in you can't explain
them
let's head back to the others
goddamnit I hope she still likes us
what about this family photo
so anyone we haven't talked to at a
I guess we got to finish this canva food
was anyone here when you guys got here
no this place was pretty wrecked we
pulled a couple of bodies out of the
office yeah
Oh his parents ah I'm fine
did you know anybody here yeah
I uh we were close I'm sorry
we found an older couple in the office
dad hauled them out in cases they
weren't really dead that's so sad come
on
what do you think about all this what is
there to think
the dead are up walking around eating
people and turning them into more more
of them it's called zambese that Jesus
need to stick together and get through
this I'm gonna get back to him now
hey there ah this is Glen and I'm kinda
in a jam here a little girl if you're
there can you put your daddy on the
phone art on the talky or whatever all
right thank you yeah what's up
so I'm down at the Motor Inn and well
I'm stuck stuck yeah Sarge has to get
some supplies for the group and a bunch
of the Roman ones got the jump on me
chemically mining over here but they
won't me what's up Glantz trapped down
at the motor in a Glen we're gonna talk
it over and send a group to come get you
all right awesome I'll sit tight till
then sounds good
I'm gonna hold on to this until we get
Glen back
I'll take good care of it what do you
think I think Doug's that great around
some bees you got your family here
I'll take Carly and her Deadeye down to
the motor in get glinted get back here
as fast as I can
that's what you want to do somebody's
got to yeah um I'm in aa doesn't sound
too bad there right now let me know as
soon as you want to head out I could use
a jog all right we're gonna kick some
butts some zombie butts
the zombie butts all right let's go
let's just go this gap Isis cow gneisses
go where are they let's just go
I just go where are they I've dad what
are you doing anything I can do ducky no
ducking barrel what are you doing it
Oh we could walk here Amy no sock Carly
you're a pretty good shot well you don't
[ __ ] with a reporter especially one
that's three days out from her last cup
of coffee I'm sure we will though sorry
um
I'm ready to head out who to hit oh you
got it you yeah let's go
goddammit I wanted to talk to Clementine
before I left well you gotta do what you
gotta do my huh you got him through what
you got in there showing on get down
oh he's so sexy I want to kiss him and
then I want this haircut I like it style
so like I don't give a [ __ ]
and he's like giving the other people
back massage sure did beep ready to
shoot
be ready oh no glad you're here Jesus
Glenn I don't think it's Jesus all right
that wasn't so hard
can we get out of here before any of
these things notice us not yet
there's a survivor trapped up there no
way we gotta go now listen I was out
here looking for gas and then up there
in the corner room I heard crying to me
uh who is it it's a girl we talked and
she got frightened
I was trying to get in to help her and
she started yelling and saying I was
bitten I tried to convince her I wasn't
and that's what
Weston look I've almost got me and I
ended up hiding in the ice machine
lucky you now let's go we can't just
leave her damn right we can
you guys are suicidal over a girl I'm
saving her with or without you think
about it Wow look at you fine
let's go save Glenn's damsel in distress
yep oh [ __ ]
am i doing this I don't want to do this
whoa am i Jesus now I think I'm Jesus
guys I'll make you a zombie later and
well it's giving him back massage
that's very polite oh okay I'm not Jesus
this player goddamn it don't know how
hard it's gonna be to get her out of
that room yeah so we have to kill every
one of them in here quietly noise
attracts these things let's have a look
around
alright let's kill them Bambi's Wow
before too long and you will be seen go
down whoa well that's one homeless buddy
what are you looking at
I saw one working on the other side of
that car okay what am I doing here
exactly
we can hide by that RB they've required
and keep our heads down
uh okay let's go I like a peeking gets
you shown but not sneaking [ __ ]
behind him there we go
all right let's plan B god damnit I
don't have one oh [ __ ] me
okay what do you got little naked except
for Carly's gone and we can't use that
much um I'm not sure I can take the boat
out myself
even if I had a weapon okay what's your
plan brah oh yeah let's go back nice but
sup Carly you really keep that post
don't you guys like to decide what is
this there's a pillow over there yes we
can flee got when it came to supply come
on I have an idea for it we can put it
and pretend we have boobies under our
shirt and then the sob is really
whatever mine I really curious what I'm
having in mind actually
alright let's head over here then is
that good pickup stir it then add scowl
I really want to get into that room
uh-huh
she's probably okay what's your plan now
genius well let's check it out then brah
hmm a screwdriver no no no quiet hey man
that drew some attention be careful uh
this is the killer with that I don't
really know we have any tricks for
getting into cars not without tools
making a bunch of noise and numb with
pillows and none of them would tell us
um well [ __ ] what do we got over here
then is it really alive
so sexy get out you're good boys just
follow my lead
just follow me don't question me woman
uh hey hiya dad hi guys huh really
that was sick those doesn't make sense
really all right I'll take it
are we doing that
why did I go back here what are we doing
guys let's go all right see what we can
do this this can probably make it go
back or something ah
let's go inside huh what are we doing
okay I can't do it uh [ __ ] nothing there
what about the door Oh exciting what is
this a spark plug
what can we do in this oh we could start
the car
ah let's do it spike if a more clog you
should hold on yeah what do we got how
how the [ __ ] are you thinking about that
push it
well can't push it oh we can oh oh oh
we're gonna again watch out dude no I
was just out damn that hard that was
awesome we are being super stealthy and
awesome now can use a spark plug
what let me see the spark okay you're a
really Oh
oh my god oh my god
wow you're larger than oh there's still
on give a [ __ ]
you're awesome zombies keep doing what
you're doing give me that all right that
could scramble a brain pretty good
that's exactly what I was thinking
really all right let's charge him let's
go back here and charge him
all right let's kill him well I'm
killing zombies let's go over there
you know the notice he's an idiot I
really want to get into that room what
what's wrong with your eyes
I think he's a zombie all right whatever
I what are we doing
let's go I'll wait for him to get closer
oh ah ah for the park hell ami closing
in I would like to end this episode a
breath like a favorite if you enjoyed
gotta come abroad today now see you next
episode of a brand mcpixel zombie nation
and he's hunting a ps3 and it's calling
from his bed my picture out yeah let's
make what's up I have bomb beer Oh a
bomb